enrique iglesias
and anna kournikova are celebrating
their twins
the former tennis pro shared these two
picks to instagram in honor of lucy and
nicholas turning three
both posts were simply captioned three
of course enrique and anna are
also parents to daughter lucy who they
welcomed earlier this year
four months two years and then one month
so
i'm not sleeping but um i'm having a
great time i can
i i mean i wouldn't change it for
nothing in the world a source tells et
the pair and their three kids are
enjoying their quiet time in miami
our source also says quote since the
addition of their daughter
earlier this year the focus has been on
her but also giving the twins
their alone time and enrique and anna
are very private and have been
protective of the twins during covid
with not many people getting the chance
to be around them
tennis player or a performer which one i
do
any direction with your child i can
honestly tell you've had to pick one
definitely sports yeah yeah i i would
say
yes um
i don't know i i just because i i love
sports um so i love golf i love tennis
um i wouldn't mind seeing one of my
little girls playing tennis
obsessive fathers but i told i told that
i said you could be the best coach in
the world
we love to see the couple sharing more
of their family on insta
since they're usually super private back
in 2014 enrique said he knew
he wanted to be a dad one day there's
days that i'm like
you know i could see myself having
children and
being a father but at the same time i
just
i want to make sure and i'm i want to
make sure that i'm
here for them as much as possible do you
guys play ever you and anna uh we do
i think i can beat her but that's what i
say all the time but she lets me win
the couple has been together for nearly
20 years they met in 2001 when she
starred in his music video for escape
[Music]
when you shot the video for the title
song
escape that's when you met your
girlfriend
yeah that is i'm embarrassed to say that
actually i i always try to tell peop
i lied to people when i tell people that
i actually met my girlfriend before
because i don't want to tell them that i
met my girlfriend
on set but despite the long-lasting
relationship
the pair have yet to confirm if they're
married
though her full name on instagram might
be a clue
you